straight talking no nonsense and
annoying all the right
people tonado paniz sensor explosions
Rock Israel and Gaza as a deadly
conflict intensifies fears grow for
those taken hostage by terrorists will
have the
latest protesters Target sakir st's big
conference speech but can anything take
the glitter of his bid to be pm
and the woman who knows more about
Sparkle and glitter than anybody else on
the planet be do a bit of Glamour in our
lives right now the incomparable Dame
Joan Collins returns live and
[Music]
unsensed live from the news building in
London this is pi Morgan uncensored good
evening oranda welcome to Piers Morgan
unsensed more than 1500 people are dead
in Israel and Gaza Israel says it's now
secured its borders but the conflict is
spiraling out of control this horror
began with of course a Savage series of
attacks by Hamas terrorists who raped
murdered pillaged and shot their way
through Villages populated by peaceful
and innocent people they executed the
elderly at bus stops they took babies as
hostages one report tonight says that
maybe 40 babies were murdered some of
them
beheaded everybody knows the scale of
this
we've all had to see the appalling
videos it's a sign of the times we live
in these atrocities were broadcast live
all over social media but is also a sign
of the times that tribalism has blinded
many people to basic Humanity across the
world Israel's critics have responded
with to the tragedy with pure poison a
letter signed by 31 student groups at
Harvard supposedly one of the world's
top universities claimed Israel is
entirely responsible for these Terror
attacks a crowd on the steps of Sydney
Opera House did
this Pro Palestinian activist danced
through London in joyous
celebration in the heart of London's
Jewish community at kosher restaurant
was ransacked and pro Palestinian
graffiti scrolled on a bridge in New
York and activist brandish placards
saying by any means necessary and
resistance is Justified they've all
completely lost their minds this wasn't
resistance this was a massacre this was
mass murder By nihilistic terrorists
intent on killing any Jewish people that
could come across of any age from
grandmothers to little babies Maggie
Chapman a green party member of the
Scottish Parliament retweeted don't let
the Western media fool you into thinking
it's terrorism this is
decolonization the former porn star Mia
Khalifa shared a picture of terrorists
on the way to a murderous pillage and
called it a Renaissance painting
journalist njar Sharie said what did you
all think decolonization meant
losers without making this political
what do these mostly left-wing people
imagine they have in common with an
islamist terror group why can't we even
universally condemn a terrorist attack
of this scale and appalling nature
without making it about our preconceived
opinions a lot of this stuff is just
anti-semitic buge dangerous anti-semitic
buge we you call it out for what it is
the Israel Palestine debate is emotional
and it's complicated I can honestly say
in 30 years of being a journalist I've
never got the kind of reaction I get
when I talk about this uh and it's on
both sides and it's extreme and both
sides have full just Jus ification
historically in claiming atrocities by
the other side but we haven't seen
anything quite on Miss scale before many
innocent people on both sides are going
to die in the conflict that's now raging
it's an enormous human tragedy on
furling and with grim irony a lot of
people have forgotten their Humanity
just remember that when nearly a
thousand people are murdered in such a
Despicable manner the only human
response is to say you are outraged
well for more I'm joined from Montreal
by The evolutionary behavioral scientist
and author Professor Gad sad Gad uh it's
heartbreaking I mean I as I came on air
tonight I heard the story of of uh
allegedly you know it's not been
completely verified but there are
soldiers reporting that in one Village
they found the corpses of 40 babies some
of whom have been
beheaded uh and we know that uh
grandmothers who survived the Holocaust
were dragged off and kidnapped and God
knows what's happened to them uh these
are unspeakable acts of
depravity what is your reaction to this
well of course I'm uh devastated by it
but frankly not to sound uh flippant
about it it doesn't surprise me for your
viewers and listeners who may know me I
hail from Lebanon we're Lebanese Jews
when I was 5 years old in 1970 in
Lebanon and Gamal abdan Naser the
president of Egypt died the way that the
people on the street were uh mourning
his loss were was to have demonstrations
singing death to Jews what did the Jews
have to do with the fact that the
Egyptian president had just died when I
was in grade four and the teacher said
everybody stand up and say what you want
to be when you grow up one of my friends
with whom I played soccer stood up and
said when I grow up I want to be a Jew
killer when we left Lebanon to move to
Canada during the Civil War and the can
canadi the pilot had said that we are
now out of Lebanese airspace my mother
put a star of David around my neck and
said now you don't have to hide your
identity and you can be proud of you who
you are so this has nothing to do with
colonialism and fighting for this piece
of land or that piece of land it's an
existential battle where one group of
folks don't believe that the other group
has a right to exist there with
self-determination once we get rid of
that mindset there could be peace
I mean I I got to say I don't think
peace has ever looked further away uh in
this conflict I really think the scale
of this atrocity is so appalling that it
will
demand probably a disproportionate
response now from Israel I don't think
prime minister Netanyahu will feel he
has any choice but to hit Palestine
harder than it's ever been hit and of
course that will cause the death deaths
of many thousands of completely innocent
people many of whom may share a view
that Hamas are a bunch of terrorists uh
and so it goes on I just don't see how
peace gets forged after this kind of
thing I I agree look I'm a by Nature by
disposition I'm an optimistic person but
I get a lot of calls and emails from
people saying to me will there ever be
peace and I I hate to admit but I think
I share your uh your view and again it
comes from the fact that there is one
group of folks who do not believe that
another group of folks have right to
self-determination sure they can
tolerate them sure they could have them
as second class citizens as demies
that's an Arabic word for second class
citizen who's protected and tolerated of
course until you're not but they don't
view the Jews as a people who are
allowed to exist with their own
individual Nation self-determination
autonomy and until that is resolved this
is going to go on at infinum I want to
play a clip now this is from President
Biden speaking just a few minutes ago in
the United
States that the United States stands
with Israel we will not ever fail to
have their back we'll make sure that
they have the help their Citizens need
and they can continue to defend
themselves Israel has the right to
defend itself and its people full
stop there's never justification for
terrorist attacks and my
administration's support for Israel's
security is Rock Solid and unwavering
I mean God you know strong words from
President Biden it's taken him a few
days to say them I have to say um I
guess the problem I have with this
is Israel is going to go in like I said
incredibly hard into Gaza I I imagine
many thousands of people are going to
die here uh the situation in Gaza will
simply get worse it's already pretty
intolerable for the 2 million people who
live there many of whom are young people
who live really hopeless lives with very
little chance of ever getting out of
living the dreams that most people have
you know I understand on the Palestinian
side why they have felt oppressed I
understand it um I don't think you can
play water abouty at this moment after
Mis atrocity and it doesn't excuse the
appalling depravity that's been
perpetrated by Hamas but I do understand
why people in Palestine feel oppressed
and I don't know how this resolves
itself in the M the short to midterm or
indeed long term and and I hate that
feeling of helplessness about this well
it resolves itself when your moral
calculus is outraged whenever any
innocent is butchered in any place right
so when I watched videos of Isis taking
1,500 Muslim men and putting bullets in
their head I was Furious I was angry I
didn't have a tribal calculus that says
I am Jewish so who cares if Isis kills
Muslim men so if I see a Palestinian
child who is a complete innocent
bystander in the war who is you know
blown up I'm angry by the same token if
you're seeing Holocaust Survivors and
Jewish babies being decapitated then boy
is your moral compass broken if you
can't Garner a bit of kindness and
sympathy for their plight I completely
agree uh Gad you speak so much sense as
always great to talk to you thank you
very much thank you sir well join me now
as a man many of us know as a famous
television personality he's also a
former Israeli paratrooper who fought
him the 1967 Six Day War and he's a
long-term friend of Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and that's
URI
gella URI great to talk to you I wish it
had been in happier circumstance we've
talked many times over the years uh what
is your response to what has happened
here okay Pierce first of all thank you
very much for inviting me onto your show
and I would like to correct correct you
because over
1,200 people were slaughtered and you
said it children babies elderly women
men you know what dogs were shot dogs
pets were
shot I mean I'm I'm outraged and I would
like to say that over 3,500 people are
injured
maimed who how who knows how many tens
of thousands are psychologically hurt
physically inside their mind they will
never forget this and I would like to
mention this is very important that this
is the worst tragedy to happen to the
Jewish people since a holocaust just
think about that the number of Israeli
deaths is equivalent now listen to this
to ask if
36,000 people were killed in a single
attack in America and there's no doubt
Iran is behind the attack you know even
if we don't have yet solid proof there
is no doubt that Iran made the
conditions the right conditions for this
attack to be possible and exactly the
same way as Hitler made the Holocaust
possible I am outraged I'm angry like
the millions of Israelis are angry how
could this have happened let me ask you
I call this first let me let me ask you
I I completely agree I share I share
your outrage here um and it can only be
immeasurably worse if you're Jewish if
you live in Israel it must be
immeasurably worse and I completely
accept that I want to just put aside
this atrocity for a moment and I want to
talk about the historic conflict and I
want to ask you how does this ever get
resolved I mean the the scale of what's
happened here is so heinous that I don't
have any hope that it can be resolved
any time soon but before that what would
you have said last week about the the
way this ever gets
resolved well Pierce look I'm I'm not a
historian um whether you're asking me
this question as an Israeli or as a
psychic or to predict how this will be
solved as an Israeli really nobody knows
yet I I'm an optimist I'm a positive
thinker I want to believe that um after
this war is finished and God knows where
this war is going to take us but um I do
believe in diplomacy I do believe in
negotiations and I think in the long
long run because I'm an optimist I
believe that there will be
peace there has to be peace what do you
feel let me ask you what what do you
feel about the the plight of the
Palestinian people going back decades
now I mean there can be no disputing the
fact that 2 million people live in
appalling conditions there very few are
able to get out of there um their
conditions have just now obviously got
10 times worse and many will say well
good they deserve it but many of them
are completely innocent people uh their
women children will get killed as well
in this process and I just wonder what
how do you deal with Gaza I mean what
what happens there okay look you know
again tragically after this massacre the
gloves are off they have to be off
otherwise this will never never ever
stop look I feel for the Palestinian
people especially for the children
children are being hurt on both sides
you know ironically believe it or not I
am connected I support a a worldwide
charity that is based in Israel called
save a child's heart they we've saved
over 7,000 children with open heart
surgery do you want to believe this that
half of them are
Palestinians half of the kids we saved
are Palestinians so it's very difficult
for me to predict how this is going to
be solved look we have to go back I mean
in history thousands of years we the
Jewish people escaped Egypt I mean we're
prosecuted for not decades but not
hundreds of years but thousands of years
and this is one part of this frenzy of
War that is happening and is creating
chaos not only in the Middle East but
probably around the world look let me
bring back the Iranians you know for for
the Iranians now this gives time to
continue building the nuclear bomb a
nuclear bomb in the hands of Iran I mean
that's deadly worldwide I don't have to
tell you peers what would happen if a
nuclear bomb explodes in Europe forget
it forget it the whole world radiation
travels in air in W with wind it's
deadly and we have to focus not only on
this immediate conflict now but we have
to make sure Iran does not get the
nuclear bomb I agree and I think I think
IR I think although there not been
established Beyond doubt yet I think
it's pretty obvious that Hamas could not
have carried out something of this scale
without the help of of Iran in terms of
training in terms of funding in terms of
all of it and and they remain a a global
Menace and must be treated as such I
I've got to leave it there thank you
very much indeed for joining me as I say
I wish it very much and God bless you
all I wish it was in better circumstance
and my thoughts with everybody over
where you are thank you very much well
tomorrow night a huge International
exclusive as we continue to cover the
shocking events in Israel and Gaza I'll
be joined for the hour by Ben Shapiro
whose commentary on this in the last few
days has been talked about all over the
world and been going viral from America
to the UK to Australia and we're going
to have him for the hour to all these
issues what the hell do we do about this
this cannot go on this Israel Palestine
conflict cannot continue into the abyss
that we have seen in the last few days
Ben Shapiro will be here tomorrow night
R say next man who could be Britain's ex
prime minister Sak St was glitter bombed
by a protester during his big conference
speech I'll be discussing that
extraordinary security breach with my
pack after the
break
good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pi and King Q thinkig
as only room for one king man you know
what I'm saying he's mocked your weight
Trump yeah look at him fail stop working
just cuz they're skin folk don't mean
they're kin folk do you believe you can
win this war is making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning M
Lucy Ley will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what 7 years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous he was
clearly something of the face of the
ward so even more Unthinkable if this
nurse had misgendered somebody on a ward
she'd have been out the door when they
first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wealth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people gay Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
see wish I'd never met him the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes La
29 the rul can we did he say yes I have
taken drugs and they bent the rules or
lied on the visa application for and
therefore got it there needs to be an
intervention around abortion laws
Parliament is Sovereign Parliament can
determine these things the rest of the
world has watched on in sort of mounting
horror as this story has unraveled for
you it was incredibly personal the death
toll from the Titanic tragedy has risen
to 1522 and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls let it
roll
wooo if we stop producing oil the knock
on effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off chart and
this some of them they're easily
LED you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there a
threat that you'd be worried it so are
you saying that you're being overwhelmed
that you're inundated we are really
working hard for you and we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the Grand
jewry I'm the only one that has been
telling the truth you don't drink never
taken drug you're stinking Rich should
you be concerned
by if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that a
[Music]
joke welcome back to p on I'm joined by
my pack talk contributor Paul Adrian the
former editor of even standard Emily
Sheffield and the well it's not just a
broadcast he an iconic figure Adam
Bolton uh what a pack great to see you
all uh Adam
let's start with Israel Palestine you
would have reported on this conflict for
decades right as I have and I like I
said earlier I when I was a CNN in
particular and it used to air around the
world the abuse that you would get from
all both
sides over anything you said that
deviated from their implacable view was
like nothing I've ever seen on any issue
that I've ever reported on so this is a
story of extremities and now we've just
seen one of the worst atrocities in
living memory and that as more and more
details come out it just gets worse and
worse what happens
here well I think what happens is that
at the moment there is pretty much from
Western leaders support and sympathy for
Israel because remember you know if one
strip it strips it down this is a
vicious attack on civilians in Israel
and whatever you think about Israel and
the settlements in Palestine in
principle Israel has always accepted the
right of coexistence whereas Hamas has
not Hamas is committed to uh eliminating
Israel so I think they are at the moment
in spite of the demonstrations around
the world in site of idiots like Harvard
University and all the rest of it
they've got public opinion on their side
and they have an opportunity if they are
restrained to maintain that but they
won't be restrained well because there's
no public appetite in Israel for them to
be restrained I think nety you feel
humiliated by what's happened you're
supposed to have the best security
defense system in the world yeah I mean
Paul I don't see any sign that Israel is
going to be restrained in fact the
opposite and that's what worries me is
that you know there is a theory that
Hamas have deliberately goed Israel with
an act of such so they might not fall
for it that's my right right they might
not they might not but the political
pressure on netan having dropped the
ball and letting this happen may be a
catalyst for him to now go too far and
and I don't know where that leads yes
and of course we know that Netanyahu was
struggling in any event before there was
the attacks we know that Netanyahu
himself likes to refer to himself as as
Mr security that's his thing um and that
of all of course has now been dashed but
what I can say is leading on from your
question to to Adam is that we are
looking at International war crimes
unraveling before our eyes terrorism
right we undoubtedly you use that word
because I mean the BBC they they won't
see terrorism I mean I find it
absolutely extraordinary I find that
extra how you can report as they have
been I find that extraordinary the stor
babies are Mur and some have their heads
cut off and you can't say it's Terri and
a whole family of five wiped out
entirely so I I don't understand that I
really don't I think they should explain
themselves and I I I I I Echo what
you're saying I I think it is I someone
has described this as like Israel's Twin
Towers moment and I think that but as
much as we want them to show restraint I
think that's an incredibly hard thing to
do at this moment they're less some FR
though that it with hindsight it was a
mistake it was an overreaction but with
hindsight once that Fury anger horror I
can't even imagine the fury that will be
in Israel right now or amongst the
Jewish Community worldwide but as a
lawyer I think it's important for me to
point out to the viewers that when I
reference International war crimes we
going to see um an investigation in
relation to both parties and how they
have acted over the last few days this
is not just a onesided slur that I'm
flinging out there it's important for
both sides to be it is I mean this has
been well there is also the problem that
hamus is not a state so I don't think
they give a damn about international law
by the way or anything I think they just
want they are nihilists and they want to
create as much Terror as possible and
they will kill any Jewish people of any
age when they get the chance I'm just
yeah we can't necessarily say that
history is going to repeat itself I mean
this obviously was time to coincide for
example with the 50th anniversary of the
Y Kiper War I was at a meeting last
night with as it happened there a lot of
AR ambassadors there and actually it was
a bit like faulty TS they did not want
to talk about the war where was 50 years
ago right the Arab Nations basically
lined up uh and said let's see if we can
push Israel out Israel has OCC
a much more Cooperative role some of it
secret and and not openly acknowledged
in the Middle East generally with the
other Arab Nations for a time and and
with Saudi Arabia that's the
new and that's probably what's been
inspiring I suspect Iran to to encourage
they don't want
that want get they don't Israel won't
necessarily want to push Saudi Arabia
and the Gulf States into an impossible
position which if they over no I think
it's an interesting point I I hope
you're right I just fear that may not be
what happens I think we can agree
there's going to be a lot of Bloodshed
there is going to be a lot of innocent
children and a lot of innocent people
and the UN that children are a given
safe passage out of the Gaza Strip now
which I I hope they do agree to because
children and also something has to be
done about the Gaza Strip right you
can't just have these millions of people
sitting there living two million yeah
yeah two million people but living in
this tiny cramped area with very little
anyway now they're going to have all
that Stripped Away and you just think
well where where does that lead you know
you're just probably going to create two
million Martyrs right I mean that's what
will probably happen um let's move on to
Kia st's uh conference speech I thought
he was quite good today yeah I mean he's
ever going to set the world a light as
an oror he's not Winston Churchill he's
not even Neil kinck um or Tony Blair but
he's got something about him which I
think middle England which is crucial
for him will find quite relatable his
back story his family life he's coming
from nothing to be director of public
prosecutions leader of the labor party
it's a good story and he told it well
today he did but you know what I wasn't
interested in all of that what I was
interested in was actually his response
to the protest and it was fantastic and
you and I discuss all the time about
resilience and what it means to be
resilient but actually we had a
fantastic let's have a look at what
happened when he came
out
true democracy is citizen Le now you see
if you watched that in America that
protester would now be dead shot by
security but he wouldn't have got
anywhere near a leader of a party like
that I couldn't believe it I mean two
labor politicians actually one labor one
Tory wasn't it have been have been
killed yeah in the last 10 years right
by lunatics and we have a lunatic
attacking attacking the leader of the
opposition in that way see his fear from
can't that Split Second absolutely you
don't know there's something flurrying
around you there's someone putting their
arms on you and there doesn't seem to be
anyone there I mean luckily no it was it
was fine I mean I've been at both
conferences at Tori one and I was at the
label one not when that happened but it
has to be said labor liked to be more
relaxed I mean for example we had to go
through arches to get into the T one we
didn't have to go through mag arches
there but I in some ways I think that's
a good thing and and what was really
remarkable frankly was that back in the
day at Labor conferences and you're a
member of that if someone did something
like that it was more like to be a
official delegate not not some hanger on
on the FR I also thought I mean Adam
you're the best person to talk about
this but I think the you know you
followed these political figures for a
long time I just think I actually feel
right now as a a person living in this
country we've at least you've got two
grown-ups in charge of the parties whove
actually restored a little bit of
integrity and DEC a basic decency
standards to their positions right of of
prime minister and I don't want to
overate the sule but I just think after
the chaos of Boris Johnson the shambles
of Liz truss right The Madness of Jeremy
Corbin at least I feel now the next
election will be between two actually
fairly decent guys who and the debate
may be about policy rather than how nuts
they are I think there's an element of
Truth in that and I think that is rak's
intention but I have to tell you that
you look at starm speech today you look
at the labor conference you look at the
people knocking down the doors The Bu
and everyone there that looked like a
prime minister waiting and I'm afraid to
say for all Richie Sak's best
efforts it was it was a circus that's
the word they used about it with you
know Liz trust going off somewhere sella
braan going off somewhere Jacob re small
going off other Tories and with the best
in the world Richie sun does not look
like a prime minister who's in control
of his party I me em his poll numbers
aren't bad it's the parties which are
cratering and continue to creater I mean
what what do you make do you buy into K
dama could you vote for K D no why I I'm
I am a fan of RI you're with the
demonstrator I'm with I'm with I'm with
the demonstrator uh interesting the
demonstrator was asking proportional
voting and there was a referendum on
that in 2011 two-thirds of the country
just a little fact for the viewers 2000
2third of the country voted against PV
do you think they understood yeah I
think so I don't think we should say
that there was a big campaign at the
time he wanted B more than that he
wanted to abolish the the House of Lords
and turn it into a gr why why that is
that the protester today wanted to be
why don't why don't you like St starma I
think that they are borrowing the
clothes of the Tories to get in and I so
I think there's a lack of authenticity
and truth going on in the labor party at
the moment I think he's done a great job
I think he's a really nice man like you
I think he's got a great backstory I
think got great values I just don't
believe they are being authentic I think
they are literally telling a bunch of
lies to get us to
vote
also Rachel Reeves has already admitted
they are going to boost borrowing they
are going to borrow they're saying
they're not they explained that what
they're going to do borrowing for
borrowing is for longterm for long-term
projects not which you know what they
you know I've heard that from
governments of all I actually thought
the thing that got they they exuded
competence yes and that is a very good
thing if you want to run the country the
public look at it and think they look
well organized all their top brass
speakers are good talkers they look
smart they look like they're well
organized right it they've done the
basics get the Tories look a mess I'm
sorry they do and there's so many of
them all saying I need to protect my
legacy you know shouting at each other
and Liz trust banging on yeah everyone
unhappy about HS we all I would I would
if I'd been Richie soon I'd have come to
Liz trust what those female security
guards did to that protester just
dragged her out by her feet or or done
what K St actually did to Jeremy Corbin
SP out the party SP out the party um
let's talk this is on a much more
serious note Holly Willoughby has quit
this morning uh today and she's let ITV
know and this follows this awful story
last week obviously she had the whole
scandal with Philip Scofield but she
kind of moved on was back doing the show
everything seemed fine uh and then last
week it had emerged that uh somebody had
been charged with listing to commit
murder and incitement to commit kidnap
in connection with Holly um police
obviously taking it very seriously I
mean Adam everyone in the public eye
lives in horror at the thought of this
kind of thing very few of us ever have
to actually experience it it's clearly
shaken her so badly she's walked away
from one of the top jobs in television
yeah although as we know um morning
presenters come and go don't they they
do but in my case more voluntarily I
think I mean you know no but to be
everyone will obviously have sympathy
with her but there is always a problem
of ultra celebrities being targeted I
mean look at John Lennon uh and d dando
and and other things and you know one
can well understand why she's she's
wanted to step back well especially with
the Jill dando documentary actually on
Netflix right now Emily I mean it's you
know it's I really feel I've known Holly
a long time when you go into the details
of what you know what's happened you
know someone's been hired well we got to
be careful obviously he been Char these
are all allegations allegations being a
charge terrifying I mean terrifying I
think if you're if you're a mother and a
wife and you actually just want to
survive you read that and the police are
telling you that and showing you proof
and someone is charged this is not just
like a little bit bit of a story Paul
She said this is like very very
lifethreatening said I have to make this
this decision for me and my family I
will miss you all so much it's a very
gracious statement but that last line
said it all to me that this is because
she's got young kids and she's thinking
my God this is not worth it right this
is not worth it I've got one of the best
jobs on telly so what yeah there's some
lunatic out there right the awful thing
is that's not going to make her safe
unfortunately she is she's she is a star
doesn't and she is in the public eye and
she is on social media and although I I
don't think to be fair to her I don't
think she actively promotes her her
children's faces across social media but
people know she she's got children um
and can I just say because we don't get
to say it very often but congratulations
to the police because this is an example
of what happens when the police get it
right because there isn't International
aspect to this I think we can say safely
say um and so I really do want to get
that out there the police have done
their job they have investigated these
uh threats they've obviously gathered
evidence a person has been charged they
remain allegations and we'll uh see how
that plays out but clearly it's been
enough already for Holly to give up this
job and I wish her all the very best
she's a she's a great girl they known
her a long time had a lot of fun with
her over the years she's honestly what
you see is what you get she's just a
good laugh uh very talented broadcaster
sure she'll bounce back well I hope she
does but you know this kind of thing can
freak people out I I completely
understand it I really do and I you know
she got a lovely family and she's
obviously just thought I'm done appear
you know better than anyone death
threats are a nature of this job now had
them myself and I tell you what nothing
happened when I reported them no and
that still staggers me to get specific
death threats made on my son's Instagram
and reported to the police and they
weren't able to actually file charges
quite breathtaking to me uh but that's
where we are thank you P very much
indeed I appreciate it on S next next a
special guest a star from the Golden Age
of Hollywood who's also a star of the
modern Hollywood has lots to say about
the world today the great Dame Jan
Collins live and uncensored don't go
[Music]
away
[Applause]
[Music]
e
this is talk
TV
welcome back to PBG on sens I'm
delighted to be joined by an actress his
new book as I No Holds Barred insight
into her Stella Showbiz career it's
called behind the shoulder pads Tales I
tell my friends and as one of those
friends I've heard a lot of these Tales
Dame Joe colins great to see you well
great to see you too how are you
wonderful I'm pretty exhausted I've been
on the tour with my show behind the
shoulder pads again and this is my one
day off and you come in to do this only
for you pe would come are you wearing
shoulder pairs tonight a little bit of
should what what lurks behind them what
lurks all kinds of Secrets I'm not going
to tell you just have to read my book
you let me I just want to start on a
slightly uh serious though but we can't
ignore this extraordinarily sad horrible
story that's come out of Israel what
what do you make of this it's barbaric I
mean it's um one of the I can't think of
anything that has upset more other than
911 um and I don't really want to talk
about it too much because I get upset so
if you want me to be crying during your
show go ahead no I tell you I I myself I
choked up earlier reading this new
revelation about 40 babies being killed
oh my God and some of them being
beheaded and I was like how How can any
human being do that to a baby I don't
know I I don't know it's it's totally
barbaric it's not a it's not the sort of
thing a human being does no it's an
animal and I I I I just um I've been
very upset ever since this happened I've
been watching all the news I've been
reading all the reports and all I can
say is that I and you know everybody
else I'm sure is just shocked and
horrified and I mean do you remember 911
yeah do you remember how I mean we heard
all the stories all the time and you
remember where you were I mean I
remember exactly where where we were and
I think that you know we'll remember
this you like you remember you remember
images I mean I remember at 9/11 The
Haunting images of people jumping out of
the town oh my God and when we realized
what it was just how everybody felt and
this time that poor young girl who's
being kidnapped from the music festival
and you know then later you see her body
and then the poor the grandmother who
survived the Holocaust and she's being
taken away and she's just
stand sitting proudly and defiantly as
they take her away to what I mean
probably some horrific murder and you
think this woman survived the
Holocaust it's just to me it's beyond
depravity uh yeah it is it's it's
barbarism it's uh it's completely vile
and hateful and I I can't think that
anybody can possibly condone it in any
way shape or form you can't if you have
answer of humanity yeah the Holly
Willoughby story that's broken tonight
oh Holly we know Holly really well she
great fun she's a great presenter she's
been through a rough old Year anyway
with the Philip Scofield Scandal but
this is a I mean again a shocking story
that somebody has now been charged with
plotting to kidnap and and murder murder
her and her children well I I mean I
think this whole thing comes down to Too
Much social media too many people put I
mean she's there in your living room
every morning for two and a half hours
she's pretty she's funny she's cute um
she she's not too controversial but I'm
sure that occasionally she says
something that is and um somebody gets
attached to her somebody thinks she's
you know that he can go after her it's
happened to lots of people in the public
it happened to me in a little way did it
you know um yes I got this kept on
getting these letters from this man who
was in sing sing and he said that he
wanted to marry me really and he sent me
pictures of himself saying I'm in for a
murder I didn't commit well they always
say that don't they and there was a
picture of him naked lying on his H bunk
and he was a murderer well that's what
he said he didn't do it but this was
many years ago when I was a pinup girl
darling I was a pinup girl once I'm very
pinup girl now for some of
us but but but when you've look at your
career has it changed you think the
nature of that kind of attention on
particularly female stars or was it
always a bit of a problem no oh no it
has changed it's much much more before
we had to watch out for the producers
and the directors and some of the
leading men and the CEOs and the heads
of the companies and the you know the
guys who ran the studio now you have to
watch out for people on social media
that are going to try and get you and
attack you and say horrible things about
you cuz whatever you we're still human
beings we don't like people to say
nothing but also what's happened is on
social media you know I like to express
opinions right when you and by the way
so do you when we had dinner together
but but I know you're careful on social
media and I know why we talked about
this because the reaction can be
horrible right yes it can and many
people feel cow now into not wanting to
express opinions I found that so sad
well cow is not not rather a nasty word
I think um smart enough not to put
yourself in the broiling pit of hatred
and Venom which is what a lot of it is I
mean let's face it I don't go on Tik Tok
although people are saying I'd got to go
on Tik Tok Tik Tok is big is I know it's
big yeah that's you know it's the number
one news source for kids under 21 well
in the I'm not a kid under
21 you look like you're not far off yeah
sure people always say to me when they
when we post pictures of of our little
gallivanting around the world they
always say the same thing how does Joan
Collins look so young what the answer um
lucky good jeans handsome parents lots
of face cream keep out of the Sun and
read my
book or my books yeah or your book I've
read your books yeah yeah I've read the
next one coming out I'm working on it oh
of course you are I'm working on it now
yeah there's a lot that needs to be said
well this is my 19th book behind the
show is it really yeah and it's coming
out in America on the 24th of this month
and then I've been touring with the play
not the play I mean Percy and I have
been kidding each other on the stage we
get are you coming to see us on no I
want to come to see oh good good I think
other thing about you other than your
obvious uh glamour yeah is the work
ethic is what I've always loved about
you you have an incredible work I think
where does that come from parents uh I
was very lucky I had you know the
perfect kind of nuclear family parents I
had tough um father who was um quite
strong and
uh you know very strong and loving and
sweet mother who didn't want to do
anything but look after her children and
make sure that they were safe and that
they were taken care of and she gave us
the right food and um but my father had
this got a picture of him actually on
the screen yeah yeah oh yeah there you
yeah I think Percy looks a little bit
like
him pran Fran well we got a picture of
Percy to tell look at Percy he's a
handsome man pery yeah he is he's
actually he my age isn't he
I don't know I never talk about yeah
we're about the same age me and Percy
good for you I think he's aging better
than me no but I want to tell you I want
to tell you my my father's Creed said
nobody will ever do anything for you you
have to do everything for yourself and
do you believe that oh I know it's true
yeah I mean even now you ask your agent
to do some well not your agent but you
ask somebody to do something and it's
always best if you do it yourself I
think and um you know you go shopping
and anyway I oh
listen I know that's your Mantra I see
it in you every day it's incredibly my
other Mantra is eat life or life will
eat you I love that love that let's hold
that thought come back after the break I
want to talk about who could be trapped
on a desert island for the rest of your
life with any of your Leading Men which
one would it be there a Cliff Hanger for
[Music]
you
good evening I'm P Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pier and King Q I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying he's mocked
your weight Trump yeah look at him fail
not working just cuz they're skin folk
don't mean they're kin folk do you
believe you can win this war making me
cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betrayed keep it award
winning m
Lucy Ley will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about Ley wants NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what 7 years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous he was
clearly something of the face of the
world so even more Unthinkable if this
nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wealth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people gay Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we La 29 point imag
the can we did he say yes I have taken
drugs and they bent the rules or lied on
the visa application form and therefore
got it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
Rest their
souls Let It
Roll yo yes if we stop producing oil the
knock on effect is far larger than just
CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me after show
this some of them they're easily
L you can kiss my American
Air thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're in dated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should we be
concerned
by if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about
it it's all about me that's a joke
coming up on the talk Hamas fires
rockets at Israel there stories of
Terror against women and children emerge
and sakir starm is interrupted by a
protester who showered him with glitter
during his speech at the labor party
conference and Holly Willoughby
dramatically quits this morning
following that alleged kidnap and murder
plot that's all coming up at
9: Alexis
[Applause]
you listen to me Blake everything that
I've ever loved you've taken away from
me my children one by one this house
will take a deep breath Blake because
the children and this house and
everything that belonged to me it's
going to be mine
[Music]
again
do you know what that's exactly how you
look at me sometimes when we having
dinner if I cross the line um I loved
that show and you know what I love i l
it fun glamorous all of it last
night I turned on British TV on one ITV
had a Yorkshire Ripper drama BBC had a
Jimmy savel drama I was like for God's
sake just give me something I know
there's Escapist I know there's nothing
glamorous anymore it's like it's a dirty
word you know I mean I was going to wear
something more glamorous and that with a
bit of glitter but then Kia St got it
for me what do you what on politics I
know you're traditionally conservative
was it was going to happen in this
election do you think I have no idea
could you could you imagine voting for k
no no I what about Richie well of course
I mean I but he's not my mp no you know
so I mean who knows do you think he
deserves a crack at being prime minister
a bit longer or not we've had so many
prime ministers with this government I'd
like to see Boris back oh God God sake
Joan we've had this conversation you
can't be serious all right well don't
ask me
then um King Charles you've known him a
long time how do you think he's doing I
think he's doing fine yeah he seems to
be very lowkey you don't read a lot
about him I mean you read a lot about um
Kate and William or Katherine and
William and um you read a lot about the
the Little Boy George but you there
doesn't seem to be very much about the
in the newspapers or on TV I think he's
doing a good solid job from what I can
see yes hard to be exciting when you you
inherit it after 70 years are waiting
right well of course I mean I missed our
Queen Elizabeth so much I mean we were
so upset when she dies even though we
knew that this was probably going to
happen and I was I remember we were
playing with our then 7mon old baby
granddaughter sort of took our minds off
it she was just learning to crawl and um
I thought the queen was one of the most
fantastic inspirational women ever ever
I totally agree met so many times and
each time I talk about it in in my book
a lot how I met her and once she had a
glass when and I was I wanted to ask her
is that gin or water but I didn't dare
she was great I I once asked her about
um I was a Windor or buck P we looking
out of the gardens and I said you do you
like the the garden parties you have to
put on and she said well Mr Morgan let
me put it to you like this how would you
like having 12,000 complete strangers
trampling on your lawn oh yes you tell
me that story I loved it um now I want
to show you these are five men that you
mention in your book um Marlon Brando El
it's the best name dropping I've ever
read this book even better than mine
Marlon Brando Elvis presy Paul Newman
Richard Burton Jean Kelly if you could
be trapped Forever on a desert island
with one of them who would it be oh
would definitely be Paul Newman really
because he would be making the most
fabulous salad dressing and putting it
on all the leaves of all the different
trees you would be trapped on desert
island and only want to have him make
you salad dress well there would be
other things he was very Paul was very
amusing he had a great sense of humor
and he was really a word that I don't
really like nice yeah he was a just and
he fought for me to be in that movie
with him because the studio wanted Jane
Mansville and he said Jane mansvi you
know I don't want her we want Joan cuz
Joan is a good comedian and he was very
loyal and the last time I saw him was
about oh a week before he died he was
looking a little bit you know not so
well and I said how are you PJ and he
said still got a pulse which I thought
was really which in the end that's all
we can hope for isn't it I mean still
got a pulse um I tell you he also also
has a pulse I love this quote this is
from Percy at your wedding this was from
his speech Joan is my accomplice my
comrade my Confessor my confident my
fearless leader and most loyal support
of my very best friend I believe here in
we have the Arsenal to battle whatever
life has to throw at us it's my fervent
wish and my pledge tonight that I can
every day in some little way make your
life as rich and wondrous as you make
mine he is a charmer person he's the
best he is yeah he really is we have our
Rouse again but he is so wonder he's a
great man you're a great lady it's been
great to see you oh it's great to your
book is called behind the shoulder pads
the tour eight more dates I think from
Brighton to New Brighton London go see
it it's a great show great to see you
Dame Joan uncensored as ever and looking
impossibly glamorous that's it tonight
tomorrow a world exclusive with daily
wise Ben Shapiro about Israel Palestine
you won't want to miss that the whole
world is watching its
[Music]
commentary
good evening on Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pi and King Q I think
there's only room for one king man you
know what I'm saying he's moed your
weight Trump yeah look at him fail St
working just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk do you believe you
can win this war you making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it awardwinning
Lucy Ley will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about Ley once NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous he was
clearly something of the face of the W
so even more Unthinkable if this nurse
had misgendered somebody on a board
she'd have been out the door when they
first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wealth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the that resonates with people
gay Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for
the very first time I he wish I'd never
met him the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
lab 29 IM the can we did he say yes I
have taken drugs and they bent the rules
or lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it there needs to be an
intervention around abortion laws
Parliament is Sovereign Parliament can
determine these things the rest of the
world has watched on in sort of mounting
horror as this story has unraveled for
you it was incredibly personal the death
toll from the Titanic tragedy has risen
to 1522 and may God rest your
[Music]
souls Let It
Roll y yes